a case of road rage leads to one woman
shooting at another in north las vegas
and penis police are now looking into it
the victim spoke with 8 news now
reporter victoria saha about what led to
that intense scene
an aggressive driver taking it to the
extreme i did see her point something
and then i heard it
that's kimberly and her mom screaming in
terror kimberly does not want us to show
her face because she's still shaken up
from monday morning's incident she says
she was driving behind this light blue
camry in north las vegas near civic
center and las vegas boulevard once it
turned green she didn't move
and so
i waited a couple seconds and
she was looking down so i waited and i
beeped at her she was holding up traffic
so i kind of tried changing lanes maybe
go to a different lane i went to the
left lane in the middle and she followed
me it wasn't until they got near losi
where the other driver pulled out a gun
fired it and then drove off and she just
kept basically kept cutting me off until
we reached losi where she turned with me
right
and
that's where i recorded one of the
videos one bullet went through the back
passenger side of kimberly's car and
went through the other side a location
where kimberly would usually have her
little niece and nephew sit it was
frightening because it was a really
close call kimberly still does not know
what could have caused this person to
put kimberly's life in danger you can't
know what they're going to do or how
they're going to react to something so i
think that's that's what frightens me a
little bit victoria sahil live local now
while police work to track down that
driver the department shares
advice here to avoid road rage incidents
don't respond to aggression with more
aggression and if you feel you're in
danger drive to a public place like a
hospital or substation and if someone is
threatening you stay calm call 9-1-1
with your location